l'effet mes chers collègues sont devenus
des objets de débats
les fait pas la signification qu'on peut
leur donner les causes qui les détermine
les conséquences qu'on en tire tout cela
devrait être le débat politique mais il
nous faut en ce début de siècle nous
battre simplement pour dire la vérité
des faits et la vérité des faits c'est
que les vaccins contre la copie 19 sont
efficaces comme peu le vaccin l'on était
qu'ils sont sûrs et qui sont notre
meilleure arme pour réduire la pandémie
à l'état d'un bruit de fond sans graves
conséquences économiques sanitaires et
sociales sans eux tout notre pays aurait
subi à l'arrivée du variant delta ce
qu'on subit ceux de nos territoires où
les populations sont trop peu vaccinés
il nous faut maintenant avec les vaccins
fournir un dernier effort un effort
collectif en juillet dernier pour
justifier la vaccination obligatoire de
certaines professionnelles contre lacko
vide le gouvernement a mis en avant leur
devoir d'exemplarité leurs
responsabilités et titille la vie des
personnes vulnérables face à un virus
imprévisible dont les mutations continue
de menacer la résilience de notre
système de santé est bien la
responsabilité de la lutte contre cette
épidémie ne peut reposer évidemment que
sur ces seuls professionnels elle est
bien entendu collective et chacun doit
d'entre nous doit y prendre sa part
cette responsabilité collective elle
comprend le respect des gestes barrières
oui mais la dernière étape pour donner
pour tourner la page de cette épidémie
nous devons la franchir tous ensemble en
mobilisant larmes la plus sûre et la
plus efficace le vaccin par essence se
faire vacciner un geste solidaire après
117 1000 décès et un coût de la crise de
plus de 400 milliards d'euros pour les
finances publiques
qui parmi nous peut se permettre de
faire l'économie d'un tel geste nous
avons les moyens avec la vaccination de
nous rendre collectivement mètres de
cette épidémie pour la transformer en un
phénomène à bas bruit
contrôlé sur le plan sanitaire une très
grande majorité de français se sont fait
vacciner et il aspire donc légitime à ce
que les restrictions cesse
cet objectif il est à notre portée si
nous parvenons à court terme à un taux
d'immunité d'origine vaccinale ou
naturels d'au moins 90% il nous manque
environ 9 millions de personnes à
immuniser pour atteindre ce niveau de
protection collective et ce n'est pas le
pass sanitaires dont les effets
maintenant s'essouffle considérablement
qui nous permettra d'y parvenir avec
seulement trente mille primo vaccination
par jour maintenant nous ne pouvons
espérer atteindre 90% de la population
vaccinée comme ça a été dit par patrick
anr avant l'été prochain or d'ici là la
probabilité que nous connaissons une
nouvelle vague existe bel et bien avec
tout ce que cela comporte
d'hospitalisation de décès et de kovy de
l'ombre même si nous pouvons espérer que
notre système de santé ne serait pas de
nouveaux saturé sommes nous prêts à
prendre ce risque à côté d'une petite
minorité bruyante d'anti vax j'entends
surtout cette majorité de français qui
s'acquittait de cet acte citoyen qu'est
la vaccination
j'entends les deux français sur trois
qui soutiennent l'obligation vaccinale
universel c'est pourquoi le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui propose
inclure dans la liste des vaccinations
obligatoires
la vaccination contre le sar skov 2 tout
en ménageant entièrement au gouvernement
la souplesse réglementaires nécessaires
pour son déploiement en termes de rythme
et de populations à ceux qui opposent
qu'une obligation vaccinale est
inopérante faute de moyens pour en
contrôler le respect je fais appel à
leur mémoire
l'obligation vaccinale c'est vraiment
pas une nouveauté dans notre pays la
variole au début du siècle dernier la
diphtérie le tétanos la tuberculose la
poliomyélite autant de maladies qui
faisait chaque année sensiblement moins
de morts que le coc vide et que nous
avons maîtrisé grâce à la vaccination
obligatoire
caisse les sanctions encourues pour
faire respecter ses obligations
vaccinales historique des amendes contre
avant quand contraventionnelle et rien
d'autre
or qui ici peut dire que la vaccination
obligatoire contre ces maladies n'a pas
fonctionné
l'existence d'une contravention
implique-t-elle ou contrôler chaque
individu à chaque coin de rue non et les
exemples récents de l'obligation
vaccinale universelle contre le coc vide
en nouvelle calédonie
l'exemple des obligations vaccinales
voter en 2018 montre que la hausse des
personnes vaccinées a été obtenue en
amont de toute sanction je n'ai aucun
regret des propos que j'ai tenus ici
dans cet hémicycle en 2018 face à celles
et ceux qui rejetaient déjà l'obligation
vaccinale car les flots ont parlé et la
vérité des faits oui la vérité des faits
encore une fois c'est que les objectifs
ont été atteints et rapidement et que
nous sommes un en phase d'éradication de
ces maladies contre lesquelles notre lit
plus tu patines et stagner s'enliser ce
sont des enfants qui ont été sauvées et
ce sont des enfants qu'elles seront
épargnés de lourdes complications
il nous faut donc regarder au delà de la
sanction comme gage d'effectivité et au
delà de la contravention la mise en
place d'un passeport vaccinale seul aux
modèles récemment décidé en écosse c'est
à dire limité à certaines situations à
haut risque pourrait effectivement
renforcer le vote de l'obligation enfin
ne sous-estimons pas l'impact
psychologique d'une obligation vaccinale
car dès lors que le vaccin est
obligatoire et non plus seulement
recommandé sa perception comme outil
efficace de santé publique en sort
renforcé et cela aussi c'est démontrer
alors mes chers collègues l'obligation
vaccinale est une politique d'aller vers
ne sont pas antinomiques tout au
contraire l'obligation en plaçant l'état
en situation de devoir favorise cette
allée vers et encore une fois l'exemple
le plus récent celui de la nouvelle
calédonie l'illustrent les élus ont
adopté l'obligation vaccinale universel
le 3 septembre les communauté kanak
isolées ou en conséquence demandé à
l'état ou aux commissaires de leur
amener le vaccin en utilisant les
hélicoptères de l'armée et ce fut fait
depuis la part des personnes vaccinées
est passé de 31 à plus de 70% c'est
aussi pour cette raison que le président
du département le plus défavorisé de
métropole soutien et demande l'
obligation universelle
au fond cette proposition de loi porte
la conviction que la défense de
l'intérêt collectif et la plus efficace
pour protéger une société cette
conviction doit émaner de chacun de ses
membres oui mais elle doit aussi savoir
lorsque c'est nécessaire lorsque c'est
légitime être celle de la loi
je mesure dans ce débat sur l'obligation
qu'ont bien des années de progression
d'invidu et alisme ont fini pour
certains à un extrémité de l'échiquier
politique est vraiment l'extrémité ont
fini par transformer
ce bien si précieux que sont nos
libertés en individuel en un égoïsme
sociétal maquillée avec une parfaite
indécence en acte de résistance
oui c'est un choix politique que de
décider alors de l'arbitrage de ne pas
réserver les obligations à certains
soignants ou gendarmes et dans des dents
d'exonérer d'autres catégories de la
population
mes chers collègues la commission des
affaires sociales vous le savez a rejeté
ce texte que je vous invite à titre
personnel adopté en tout cas je pense
qu'il poursuit utilement un objectif que
nous partageons certainement
rassembler l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
dans un effort collectif pour vaincre
cette épidémie et tourner la page d'une
crise sanitaire qui n'a que trop duré je
vous remercie
[Musique]